[Music]
all right let's go to becky in tulsa
what's up becky
hey there
welcome to the barn raisin how are we
doing
thank you so much i'm doing okay how are
you i'm good i'm good thanks for calling
how can i help
thank you so much for taking my call um
i'm having an issue in my marriage that
i i feel like i've come to a breaking
point so i just need some advice
okay um
my husband and i are a blended family he
has two children and i have one
and we've been married for almost 10
years
we took a class on blending families
before we got married and
followed the advice putting our money
together
and um
it's it hasn't been an easy relationship
from the beginning um and so there's a
lot that's gone on
between then and now
but one of the main issues that's
happening right now is related to money
so
we had our money together
when we were married my son was nine and
then his kids were teenagers and so
i kept aside the child support that i
received
from my son's dad
and we paid child support for his kids
my husband was very unhappy that i kept
the child support separate
because he felt like he had no say in
how that money was spent
and he was right
he was right yeah he was right yeah that
should have gone into the pot just to
help pay the bills to take care of your
kids
well we
because we were paying on his kids and
my son i used that exclusively to pay
for like sports band
different things that i didn't put into
our household budget i just paid for
that with the child support right and so
anyway that's not that's not the
question though but keep going
so the
over the years so after
his kids aged out of child support he
was insistent that we then set aside
money for their support
out of our budget
just continuing
and
[Music]
so that has continued over the last
several years until now they're in there
one's 22 and one is 25 they live at home
with their mom
one isn't working they don't have a good
relationship with their dad
and so i went to him
last summer and just said you know i
think it's
time that we
stop setting aside money for them
because they're adults and we can help
them on a case-by-case basis if you know
they're in a situation that they need
help
but um
i think it's time that we
take that out of our budget
and we'll do the same for my son when
he's you know of that same age
and
he was so angry that he then separated
our money
and that has just caused a ton of issues
for me
i mean i make about half of what he
makes i'm working several jobs now
i have he and shouldered with like our
car
he has a free car through work so i'm
responsible for
all things related to our car now so
so
i was a super immature response
and
um i would be willing to bet
that that money
separation issue and the holding it back
and this is this and this is mine and
that's yours that's just symptomatic of
some deeper rift in your marriage that's
probably been there for a long time
ultimately um how can i help you
so he
said in our conversations around this
that
he doesn't answer to me
in the finances
and he said that multiple times
we've we've been in therapy throughout
our marriage over
different times and there's a lot going
on like you said there's
we think maybe possibly um high
functioning autism he's just come to
that realization in the last few weeks
there's a lot of stuff there
um
but he has and even through therapy and
all that has never backed down from the
position that he does not answer to me
financially and i
i don't know i feel like that
broke our vows like i'm really
struggling with
seeing how to continue forward
if that is the view
well it's because
you answer to each other
yeah it's i mean
every thought and action should be in
service to your marriage
right so it's it's it even is deeper
than who
because that's the question i get a lot
is like all right so we're split who
gets to make the final call
and usually if you if if you have
whittled away a decision in your
marriage and it is final call there's
something else going on
yeah
right there's there's decisions that are
made that are the right decision for my
family that i don't like or that i would
have chose like if i was on my own i
would have done differently but it's the
right thing for our family a friend of
mine's taking a new job they're moving
to nashville um
i don't think they're excited about
leaving their friends i guess there's
hard stuff but it's in service to
something bigger which is our marriage
right so it's
he's not looking at it the right way
and
what about your relationship have you
set up
that it's pitted itself that way that he
feels like it's you versus him
my guess would be
this is just one of probably several
when we're all on the same page except i
got this little pot that i'm just gonna
not budget i'm just gonna spin it
however i want to
and that is
maybe that was crack number one in this
unified foundation we went to a class
this is how we're going to do this we're
all going to come together bam i'm going
to keep this whole thing on the side
and yeah you know what i'm saying and so
it there's no good to go back because
over that's happened and it's over and
done with um
but here and here we are
what else is going on in this marriage
because there's something else
i mean there's a lot of things
from the beginning he um let's get let's
go to right now
intimacy scale of one to ten ten being
incredible
peel the wallpaper off intimacy one is
like i don't even know that guy
it's a one okay what about um
conversations about where we're going to
eat like what for dinner and stuff like
that 10 being like you pick no you pick
oh he did anywhere and one is like
that's what we're having
um it's it's pretty low pretty low on
that skill
on vacation together um
we went last summer
how was it with my family
okay it won one because you went with
your family so it's yeah it's yeah it's
not good so he
and
he and both of his children are
in theory on the autism spectrum so
any kind of
disruption and routine is difficult
so
it's i mean and this is new so i'm not
even sure like he hasn't been officially
diagnosed but it would explain like
a lot of the meltdowns he's had extreme
jealousy
but
i've worked really closely with
high-functioning autistic brilliant
folks
and when i know that
there's a different style of
communication a different level of
clarity in the communication
and changes
again everybody's different and there's
not we're talking about a diagnostic
here
but
um
that one does not automatically equal
the other
right so money is not money is a symptom
here
what i'm saying is just because you go
on vacation doesn't mean everybody with
high functioning autism is gonna throw a
fit
well that is what happens well i know
and what i'm saying is if there's not a
alteration of communication if there's
not a weekly or monthly
budget slash calendar meeting that
happens every time so we can review hey
here's where we were here's what's
coming down the road so that when we get
to that do what we did we did do that we
had a monthly budget
together in it like we did it together
except you had your side your side
pocket
yes yes i mean that that's a big deal
but he's had his as well i i'm
here's what you got to do
you've got to take ownership of you
all of this conversation you keep
rolling back to him he did this thing he
did this thing he just think great he
might have
the only person on planet earth you can
change or control is you
your thoughts and your actions so the
question you have to ask yourself is do
i want to be married
what am i willing to go all in on
and how am i willing to do this and it's
probably going to start with a
um hey i shouldn't have done what i did
or i wish i could go back and do that
over can we stop the combative you
versus me language you and you you have
to do a thing for me
or you don't run you i don't answer to
you can we stop that language and just
completely scratch this thing control
alt delete and say okay let's build
something different
if you don't want to do that
then that's a whole different
conversation right if you do want to
stay married
then you're going to have to rebuild
something different than what you have
and that starts with you taking
ownership of your participation and your
role in what you have right now
yes your husband may have autism in it
you may look back and go whoa that
really explains a lot
we had a lot of challenges in the past
with communication and with frustration
and with
all sorts of of
processing and i wanted him to read my
mind and read my thoughts and he didn't
do that and then i got mad there could
be a whole backlog of that great that's
cool the question you have to ask
yourself is what are we going to do now
what are we going to do now
the the statement of i don't answer to
you about money that's not the problem
that's not the problem
that's the uh jerry maguire moment
right what you got to do is get beneath
that and say what's really going on here
and do we want to save this marriage my
hope is you do and if you do
starts with you